سن الياس مجرد وحل هذا مو كلامي كلام علمي
بالفعل هذا ليس كلام
ا هو انه سن الياس ليس الا خدعه تمارسها
النساء على انفسهن الدراسه هذه الدراسه
الفرنسيه تقول ان السيدات على استعداد
للبقاء في حاله الحاجه للحب والتواصل
الحميم حتى مع تقدمهن في العمر الطبيبه
هولي تامس التي اعدت الدراسه تقول ان
اطباء صحه المراه يؤكدون
ان لا يتوافق ابدا مع الواقع الذي يرونه
في السيدات اليوم الحب العلاقه الارتباط
غيرها مما يحقق شغف المراه في الحياه لا
يزال مهم وفق هذه الدراسه الاخيره لدى
الكثير من السيدات يعني مو سيده ولا ثنتين
بالفعل عليه مشاهدينا فان
عزائها الحقائق بان السيدات قادرات على
تجاوز الياس بالحب هذا الميدان يا حميدان
[موسيقى]
على مشاهدينا من الضب ابو ظبي الدكتوراه
منار رياحنه اخصائيه نفسيه ومعالجه اسريه
اهلا بك دكتوره منار معنا دكتورة يعني
معروف بانه جسم المراه يدخل في تغيرات
هرمونيه وما الى ذلك مع التقدم بالعمر
وهذه حقيقه يعني تختبرها كل النساء مع
تقدمهن في العمر ولكن نحن هون عم نحكي عن
يعني
كسر مفاهيم كانت سائده بانه يعني حتى حاجه
المراه للحب
للحميميه ولا الشريك وكل ذلك فعلا ايضا
تتوقف مع تقدمها في العمر ولكن دراسه
بتقول انه هذا الكلام غير صحيح اشرحي لنا
اكثر نفسيا كيف توصلت هذه الدراسه لهذه
النتيجه
يا صباح الخيرات يا صباح السعاده والتفاؤل
انا يعني ارفض بالنسبه لالي وكدراسات اني
انا احكي عن سن الياس سن الياس اصلا ما
لازم نحن نحطه في تفكيرنا غير موجود مع
المراه المراه دائما بحاجه الى المحبه في
اي وقت
المحبه هي موجوده في الداخل كون المحبه
موجوده في الداخل نحن نرفض هي عباره عن
عبارات تم تداولها زي العادات انه المراه
يعني لحالها سن الياس يعني
مشحونه بكل بكل المفاهيم السلبيه اصلا
وهي العكس تماما اجمل مرحله اللي هي
المرحله اللي نحن بنسميها في علم النفس
المرحله الملوكيه عند المراه هي مرحله
الاربعين هي الاربعين فما فوق هي بنفس
اللحظه تخيلي المسمى اللي عم بيسموه انه
السن الياس بالعكس هي اجمل مرحله من مراحل
المراه والمراه لا تت
وقع طاء اخذ واعطاء على المشاعر هي مين
يحتويها ترجع لا بيئه هي نشات فيها
العادات اللي موجوده انا ارفض انت دائما
عقلي انا الباطن يرفض كلمه ياس ما في ياس
طول ما انت انسانه مشب بالحب انت قادره
على انك تعطيه وعلى انك تاخذي رفقا في
القوارير
[موسيقى]
منار ما هذه هذا هذا دائما يمكن كان العمر
او السن اللي يقال انه المراه يجب ان
تتقاعد في عاطفيا وجسديا باعتبار هناك
تغيرات
هرمونيه تحدث للمراه هبات وغيرها اليوم
هذا هذا الامر لم يعد منطقيا وواقعيا ماذا
على المراه ان تتعامل كيف تتعامل مع هذه
المرحله العمريه الجديده
ابدا انت الان خلينا كلنا نلاحظ انها
المراه في الوقت الحالي اللي نحن موجودين
هلا فيه لاحظ كم المراه لفتره الجمال
عندها فتره العطاء عندها الفتره اللي
كانوا مطلقين عليها في الماضي مرحله اليد
لاحظ الان في عند المراه حاليا غير موجود
لاحظ يعني الوقت الحالي الوقت الحالي نقطه
معينه يعني مش مش حكينا مش نفسي بالعموم
ولكن نحكي عن نقطه معينه العلاقه الحميميه
او الحب بالنسبه للمراه في هذا السن معروف
بانه بكون في تغيرات هرمونيه كبيره بتاثر
على رغبتها في وجودها يعني بهذا الاطار مع
شريكها وهذه وهذا شيء ما بنقدر ننكره ولكن
دراسه عم تحكي بانه لا ممكن تخطيه يعني
اذا فهمنا
وبسهوله بسهوله الشخص اللي راح يحتوي هذه
المراه هلا راح تكون في البدايات اول مثلا
بدايتها هي عم تشعر انها في اشياء هي ممكن
ما تفكر انه هي مرحله الياس على فكره
بتحس انه في تغييرات عندها وضع طبيعي زي
انه
المعتاده مثلا عند المراه مثلا في فتره
بيكون اريد التغييرات في الجسم هذا وضع
طبيعي نفس
نفس المزاجي
انه اليوم اذا صار عمرها خمسين او ستين
سنه وبالتالي تغيرت وحتى نظرتها انه الرجل
زوجها بحاجه الى واحده عمرها 20 30 سنه
يتزوج امراه ثانيه هذي كيف تنعكس كيف من
الممكن انك تتجاوزها
في الخمسين اقود بنت العشرين وممكن افوز
اقول بنتي الثلاثين انا
بس راح انا انا بمارس استمر ابدا الرياضه
دائما بتعطي لاحظ هلا دائما الرياضيين
تعطيهم اعمار اقل دائما انا اهتم بطريقه
الحياه اللي انا عم بعيشها اهتم في نظام
يومي نظام اليوم عندك ابدا انا الصبح في
صحه يعني بكير بممارسه الرياضه بعمل كل
الطقوس اللي انا عم تعمل لي الرفاهيه في
اهتمامي في بيتي اهتمامي في اولادي لاحظ
المراه هل عمرها توقفت في عطائها حبها
لاولادها
مربط الفرس هون هو موضوع الحاله الذهنيه
لدى المراه كل ما كانت اكثر ايجابيه كل ما
قدرت
ساعدتها تبقى نفسها حتى في هذه المرحله
العمريه
احتياجاتها وعطائها
بنفسها
دائما العمر نحن بنحكي في القلب شو انت
قلبك عم بينبط هو يحدد عمرك
دائما ما نخلي نظ
رتنا لاهل الرجل بهذه المراحل
الرجال ايضا
نرفض هذه الادعات
شكرا جزيلا دكتوره منار رياحنا اختصاصيه
نفسيه ومعالجه شكرا جزيلا واتمنى دائما
السعاده ودوام الشباب حتى نتذكر دائما ان
الامر
شكرا جزيلا
عيشوا الحياه احبوا بعض
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات